das ist nicht wenn du da ist jetzt
knackte er da auch noch hin
hallo mein name ist luca moment eine
stunde vorher wo man wollte mein gott oh
mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott oh
mein gott oh mein gott es ist
tatsächlich das bekommen was ich dachte
was sagen gekommen
hier ist der herr der bund gestern mit
der post geliefert allerdings war den
ganzen tag in berlin
und der ist unfassbar süß war wird jetzt
mal den anderen balu kennenlernen und
zwar rufen jetzt einfach mal bei uns
namen und fragen was er davon hält nawal
was hältst du von dem anderen über lu
was sie denn von diesen ball nicht wie
bei amazon bestellt habe okay kommt
normalerweise schaue dir jetzt mal an
ja ist das nun gut oder nicht gut ja ist
das gut
ich nehme das mal als gut er ist sauber
er sagt und er ist nicht durstig das
heißt perfekt wir können jetzt mit ihm
aus jetzt kommt er da schon wieder an
ich glaube der will den anderen baloyi
kennen lernen also der balu ist ja quasi
der ballon das ist nur der virtuelle
balu und das hier ist ja klar ich
verstehe diesen runden ich kann es mir
das mal sagen wieso du hast du mal habt
ihr irgendwelche theorien wie wir das
anders aufstellen können weil lukas
nicht gleichzeitig dasein im spiel und
hier auf meiner schulter hat doch mal
hin welche theorien in die kommentare
warum der ball jetzt hier ist und nicht
mehr dem spiel oder dass der ball nur
auf der zukunft ist aber wir kriegen
jetzt erstmal auf ausgehen und zwar
gehen erstmal eine ganz simple runde
spazieren mit dem balloon möchtest du
mit balu spazieren gehen
ich nehme das mal dann ja ach ja man
kann ja eine route zeichnen die an
deinem haus beginnt und endet die
anzeige unten links zeigt wie weit ein
und laufen kann oder das ist gerade so
richtig an
es heißt ist doch der ist es ein déjà vu
yahoo dich und desto öfter beim gassi
gegangen ist erste längere runden kann
man gehen kommen weil man kann auch beim
start zu in eindhoven bestimmt nicht
diese dumme route man konnte auch am
start so ein bisschen ja genau das hat
man hier so eine kleinere kurve gemacht
jetzt hier um sammeln wir uns das hier
mal ein schaffen wir wohl noch ja wir
kriegen zwei extra sachen jetzt ich
frage mich gerade wie sobald du ein kind
ist halsband hat möchtest du mir was
sagen kann warum kann sogar springen
auch gott was jetzt passiert flasche was
freust du dich so darüber nur eine leere
saftflaschen sie hat absolut keinen wert
wir spielen vielleicht trotz man mit der
saftflaschen aber ich fühle mich
irgendwie rats mit einem papagei auf der
schulter irgendwie auch hat man nun was
hast du denn jetzt sie wieder gesehen
was machst du balu und sprung
[Musik]
ich dachte das ist ja jetzt schon wieder
in kombi kindern wieder ein geschenk
oder was sind sie jetzt heftig foto alaa
runde scheiden sich nicht sonderlich für
dieses foto zu beginn balu scheint sich
dafür schon ganz schön zu begeistert
kommen dann haben wir jetzt mal ganz
locker nach hause
ich meine sei auch ein anstrengender tag
heute schon wieder du musstest nichts
machen weil das ist nicht dein ernst man
was hast du für einen scheiß blase alter
mann übrigens sich die du bist der coole
valoren der ingame ist dieser faule
heckmann komba lubmin soll ich will nach
hause
da sind wir das ist nicht wenn du da
jetzt jetzt knackte er da auch noch ein
spaziergang kann sehr anstrengend sein
ja für seine blase und seinen darm trakt
vielleicht alter so oft wie der da
gepisst und gekackt hat geht zum haus
die bedarf und kaufen wasser für blumen
ok alles klar
die gebe ich natürlich nachher auch noch
weil ich behandle ihn schon wieder einen
echten hund und ja ich hatte in echten
hund auch hier auf der schulter sitzen
dann irgendwie das gefühl dass ökologie
und vitello da hinten so ein bisschen
eifersüchtig werden auf balou weil du
sitzt auf meiner schulter ich glaube so
fühlt sich jeder von uns besser und so
können wir in zukunft auch besser videos
aufnehmen ohne dass ich mich total voll
gepackt ihr mann freunde was ist denn
hier los schon wieder mit dann gehen wir
mal eben auf vorrat liste und schauen ob
ich für den ball irgendwie abwasser
finde ich lege trainingsbuch und paar
tausend bücher unter sport haben wir
hier wir haben tennisball in den channel
balu ich möchte mit dir spielen nicht
nur alleine wir schauen mal eben auch
mal überhaupt wasser braucht die steht
nämlich der es satt und durst es normal
und okay da gebe ich immer dann gehen
wir mal eben kurz aus gehen einkaufen
und kaufen für den ballon so ein wenig
wasser
nehmen wir hier direkt hier kommen was
da können wir ja auch mal direkt zehn
stück verkaufen müssen wir jeden zweiten
seite folge hier zusammen dem supermarkt
latschen dann kaufen auch noch zehn
trockenfutter danke für deinen einkauf
kurz haarshampoo kaufe ich mir auch fünf
stück weil balu ist nämlich kurz hat das
merkt man auch hier dran schaut euch mal
sein feld an das ist mega kurz aber
alter nur geht jetzt sogar zoneplayer
blick der guckt so ein bisschen so wie
wenn er mal genau darauf achtet schon
süße so richtig kleiner
ich will diese folge gar nicht mehr so
tausend jahre lang halten deswegen sage
ich jetzt noch mal eben kurz dass wir
ich muss ja noch ein bisschen wasser auf
jeden fall für ihn jetzt mal eben hier
hinstellen also pflege dann soll port
wasser dahin kommt kann mir hier ist das
schöne wasser fritz mal das schöne
wasser alles klar luca der kann das
wasser glaube ich nicht komplett aus
trinken weil der ja auch nicht komplett
durstig war deswegen würde ich einfach
sagen ich pack das wieder hier rein
klicken auf form und das war es dann
auch schon mit dieser heutigen folge
wenn ihr bock habt das bald in die
nächst folgenden ten box kommen dann
zeigen ist nur mit einer bewertung
schreibt mir die kommentare wie sich der
ball und dann der andere balu der hier
vorne der total ads hat und immer
irgendwie zu mir hin läuft und mit mir
spielt wie in einer verbindung
zueinander stehen und in der nächsten
folge werden wir diesen ball hier mal
waschen du hier ist natürlich
unglaublich gut dafür habe ich ja schon
äxte das kurzer shampoo gekauft dann
wenn ich mal eine bürste kaufen und so
weiter und so fort wenn ihr das sehen
wollt dann
ende